how oh how they're so few infected in
Russia why hasn't the pandemic hit
Russia harder why aren't there more
infected and that is a question you hear
more and more often in the Western press
pundits asking almost bitterly with
disappointment the how is relatively
simple its action while CNN and others
were busy bashing Trump for his racist
policies and restricting air travel with
China Russia shattered its entire border
thousands and thousands of kilometers
without ceremony no frills while Western
leaders politicians were busy soothing
their business leaders and corporate
bosses Russia established quarantine
anyone arriving in the country was self
isolated at home and talked about tests
Russia has conducted a hundred and fifty
six thousand coronavirus tests the
United States up until March conducted
just four thousand instead they have
grasped at straws citing fringe
opposition and conspiracy theories that
allege a widespread cover up more of
putin's machinations that Putin is
hiding the true infection rate well even
the World Health Organization has denied
these rumors I 99.99 percent sure that
they are no hidden cases I don't think
that we could see some cases where
people have not come forward because
they didn't want to go into South
isolation but breaking through the
network that was to catch and understand
and advise such cases was really good
while Russia has been fortunate so far
few expect the pandemic to completely
pass Russia by hospitals and clinics are
increasingly being prepared to receive
the infected to work in quarantine mode
about 60,000 people in Russia are either
under quarantine itself
halation or under medical observation
for the moment surveillance is so well
done including in the community acquired
pneumonia which are of other causes
which are all tested for corona that i
think we would see it also if we would
had severe cases of corona and would
have it because of the demographic
structure in russia we would see an
increase a sharp increase in that and
finally I can tell you I have informally
asked a huge I would say network of
people I know in Russia asking them do
you know or do you know someone who
knows someone who is in hospital for
pneumonia or who has lost someone and I
couldn't find a single person who
answered positive to that who could have
predicted that the sanctions intended to
bow and Russia would save it
cushion it in these times of worldwide
economic recession see the point of
those sanctions was to deprive Russia of
this of donnas in Europe's loans and
financing for the central bank the
government oil companies and businesses
so what Russia did would switch to this
the rubles now foreign debt is at a
record low Russia produces almost
everything it eats ninety percent of
what it eats Russian agriculture
producers for its now the other needs it
turned to China now Russia is set up to
weather this storm with a half trillion
dollar fund that it set up just in case
now is that case Russia will be a bit
better off than other countries because
of this experience because of sanctions
and because of reserves when the virus
threat passes it's possible things will
come back to life faster in Russia than
in other countries because there won't
be the negative drag of debt the end
result has been the shelves at
supermarkets and shops are still packed
with everything you could ever want
while there has been something of a run
on supermarket
shops in the hoarding well they still
sell toilet paper and plenty of it
you